[MUSIC PLAYING]
- So welcome to the
Data Science Hangout.
A little different today in
that I'm hosting, not Rachel.
Rachel is on a train right
now, right now down to the
Philadelphia area.
But this is the Data
Science Hangout.
We host it every Thursday
at noon, same time, same place.
There are a few ways to
participate in the Hangout. It's
meant to be super casual,
open conversation, questions
about data science.
You can participate just
by typing in the chat.
We obviously encourage that. Raise
your hand and hop in
live and ask a question.
And then there's also a
way to submit questions anonymously
via a Slido link that
my colleague Hannah
will provide.
So do whatever you
feel comfortable with,
have your video on video off,
whatever you feel
comfortable with.
We'd love to hear from
as many people as we can.
But I'm super pumped to
introduce our featured leader
today, JD Williams from Zoetis.
And I'll hand it
over to you, JD,
if you want to
introduce yourself.
- Great, thank you.
Welcome, everyone.
Glad to see you all here.
I was scheduled to be here--
I think it was three weeks ago,
four weeks ago. I can't
remember what it was. And I got
COVID. And you would not want me
to have been here on the call
at that time.
It was actually my third
infection of COVID in
the past three years.
I do not recommend any more
than one or any infection of COVID.
But glad to be recovered.
A little bit of a groggy
voice kind of still hanging out after
this time. But hopefully
you can hear me OK.
Really excited to be here.
So I have a slide that
I've used to introduce myself and
other team members on my
team and use it to introduce
themselves as well.
I'll put it up
as a way to get started here.
OK, this is me. So
just a little bit about
me and my background.
I
grew up in the Rocky Mountain
West. So this is the area of
Colorado, Idaho,
Oregon, Utah. So I love the
mountains. And so I live now
in flat old
Indianapolis, Indiana.
So I'm a little bit depressed
about the terrain or the lack
thereof. But love this
location, great people, great
community, great schools.
So I live here, and I'll
give a little bit about that journey.
So
coming from that background,
I went to Brigham Young
University in Provo, Utah for my
undergraduate degree, which
was in mathematics education.
My original plan was to be
a high school math teacher.
And then through the
course of some events,
I ended up getting
into statistics,
the master's
program there at BU
in the statistics program
and absolutely loved it.
And then took that
opportunity to
then go on to do a
PhD in statistics,
and that was at Virginia
Tech in Blacksburg, Virginia.
So hopefully, there are some
Hokies or some Cougars out
there. If you are, give
a thumbs up for those alumni.
The stats program at Virginia
Tech is the third oldest
statistics program
in the country.
And so it has a really,
really long history.
And the area of my dissertation
research was in the area of
multivariable statistical process
control which comes
actually full circle.
I'll talk a little bit about
some work that we're doing in
the area of manufacturing and using
Posit to help us there as well.
So a little bit around the
work experience journey--
after graduating with my
PhD, I started to work at GE,
General Electric in their
research headquarters.
This was in upstate New York
and really loved it there.
GE at the time owned a
little bit of everything.
And so you think about GE,
it's not just kind
of light bulbs
and dishwashers and
things like that, but
they used to have
this large capital financial business.
So we would lean--
loans and leases of
all kinds of equipment.
So that's where I got
into the area of financial services.
And that led to a role with
JPMorgan Chase and their
analytics headquarters and that
was actually in Columbus, Ohio.
So move the family to Ohio
and was there for a couple of
years. And that's
where I really learned
the concept of big data. And
by the way, this was like 2010.
It's kind of time
frame big data
and just really
using vast amounts of data
to make decision making.
And the banking,
the financial industry I feel
like has been kind of well
ahead in the analytics curve.
For example,
at JPMorgan Chase,
I never heard
of anything in terms of
an analytics project.
It was just the
way things were.
It was part of the
DNA of the company
whereas when I took my
next role at Dow AgroSciences,
I was asked to come and
start up a brand new business
analytics team. So I went and
hired a small team and really,
we were just starting from
scratch and trying to get
analytics use cases going.
And everything was in terms of
project and use cases and just
trying to get momentum and
get buy-in from various
stakeholders whereas where
I come from a place where
there was no major decision
made unless the analytics team
signed off on it and it
was such an integral part of how
decisions were made.
So it's quite a learning
experience and to go to a place
where we had to sort
of prove ourselves.
And so the Dow AgroSciences
role took me and my family here
to Indianapolis, Indiana.
Now Dow AgroSciences doesn't exist.
So Dow and DuPont merged
to become Corteva and
that was happening
while I was there.
I had a really great
experience with Dow.
And then
here in Indianapolis is
the headquarters for Eli Lilly.
And I had the opportunity
to come into Lilly
and basically take an
advanced analytics team of
PhDs and statistics and operations
research, et cetera,
and grow that team and
expand it across the globe
to be not just US centered,
but also Japan, China, Europe, et cetera
and as well as expand
our different types of
work we're doing within the US.
So really great opportunity to work
and learn in a highly regulated space
of how analytics can
make a difference.
And then two years ago--
this is during the pandemic.
So February of 2021,
I had the opportunity
to come here at Zoetis
with just an amazing
opportunity to basically create
and lead a brand new
business insights
and analytics team.
And so basically, I was given
like a blank sheet of paper
to draw out the
organizational design,
write the job descriptions,
and go and hire the team
to accomplish the vision of
leading in digital
and data analytics,
which is one of the company
priorities that's
been publicly stated.
And just recently,
that priority was rewarded and
slightly to be now we're going
to power the business through
digital and data analytics
capabilities. So really
happy about that.
So I'll come back and talk
a little bit more about the team,
but kind of finishing
the story here.
On the personal side, my
wife and I have five kids.
You can see our picture there.
Our oldest is going to
get married this summer.
Very expensive, I know.
So just prepare for any of
you parents out there who have kids
in that getting ready
to get married stage,
start saving now, especially
if you have daughters.
So anyway, we're in
that phase right now.
And
also, for fun, I've competed
in things like Ironman triathlons.
I've completed six of those.
I've
qualified for
and competed in the Boston
Marathon as well. That
was an amazing experience.
It took me more than
10 years of effort
to actually go on and qualify
to be able to run
in the Boston,
which is a whole story in and
of itself of how I use data and
analytics to help me get
there, which is so cool.
So maybe if we
have time later on,
we can talk about how data
analytics help me to facilitate
improving to get to where
I could qualify for Boston.
And in back in college--
this is when I was at BYU--
as an undergrad, I was
a former competitive ballroom dancer.
You can see from
that picture there.
I was having way too much fun
as you can tell as an undergrad
on the ballroom dance team.
And also,
between my freshman and
sophomore year of college,
I took a two year leave of
absence to serve a mission for my church.
And in these types
of situations,
we don't get to choose where
we go or what language we speak.
And I was asked to
go to Argentina.
So lived there for two
years and learn to speak Spanish.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
So I learned a little bit
Spanish there and try to keep
that up a little bit every day.
So that's a little bit
about me and my background.
Let's kind of go through
the team a little bit.
But before I jump into
that, any questions that pop up,
I'm going to talk through the
genesis of the team and the org
structure and how we work.
Any questions? I can't tell--
-
There is an anonymous question
that I think is exactly what
you're talking about.
The question is,
how do you go about building
a data science team from scratch.
- Great question. So that's
exactly what we had to do here.
- It wasn't planned.
JD WILLIAMS: Yeah, yeah. So
I've had to do this twice
now. This is the second time.
The first time was
when I was brought into
Dow AgroSciences. That was
a much smaller team, smaller
scope. That was just for the
commercial kind of scope.
In this case--
just a little bit of
background the company--
Zoetis is the largest
animal health
company in the world.
So it's an $8 billion company
with 13,000 or so
employees globally.
So if any of you have dogs
or cats, then very likely,
there's a chance that your
dogs or cats are being prescribed
Zoetis medications
from your veterinarian.
Or
any of you are associated
with livestock farming-- so cattle,
beef, or dairy cattle,
pigs, chickens, sheep, and even
salmon-- so fish
farming as well--
we have products that
help to serve those animals.
And so a little bit
about the company--
and it's really great to
be in this place where
we really--
our mission is to
help improve the world
by improving the
health of animals,
those that are companion
animals as well as those that
are used to help
feed the world.
And so in 2020,
we had a new CEO Kristin
Peck that took the helm.
And one of the first changes she
does was to bring in a new
chief information officer
who is Wafaa Mamilli.
And I had known and worked
with Wafaa at Eli Lilly previously,
and she is just an absolutely
spectacular leader.
You can go and Google
Wafaa Mamilli afterwards and read
all of the words and
the great leader that she
is as well as Kristin.
So Wafaa came in and completely
took a new direction in the
company to be technology and digital focused.
And that's where the priority
of leading in digital and data
analytics came about.
And that was really the
foundation of why my team was
created and funding
it. So not just words.
They're going to say, hey,
by words, we're supporting you,
but actually by
dollars and resources.
And so I was brought
in along with others to build
this business insights
and analytics team.
And so one of my first
responsibilities was to
understand what the business
needs are and to understand
how we can play a role in that.
And when I came in, I
realized that there were some
data scientists and pockets
of data science throughout the
company mainly in
our US commercial,
which is our major
commercial unit,
as well as in our R&amp;D group
and data science statisticians
et cetera in those areas.
And so we didn't want to
focus on those areas at first because
we knew there was already
ongoing work there and support.
And so what we did was designed
the organization to be one
where we had dedicated
focus of data analysts,
so those that are not
necessarily have master's
and PhDs in data science,
but have bachelor's
or so forth degrees in
data analytics type of degree
areas that we can focus in
particular areas.
And then I designed a pool
of data scientists that could then
be deployed across any of the
use cases and could be very
flexible kind of a pool there.
And so we focused a lot of
our initial work in the area of
manufacturing and supply chain
as well as our
international commercial business where there
was very little or none in
terms of data science support.
And so they
were immediately--
there's so much pent up demand
in these spaces that it didn't
take long for us to generate
momentum in those areas.
And we also did things like
with finance and HR kind of
other enabling functions,
but we focused mainly on
our manufacturing supply chain and
our international commercial.
And as we gain momentum,
we've expanded now to more
use cases within the US commercial
as well as in our
R&amp;D space.
So in terms of designing
the organization,
I basically just designed
to have an analytical lead--
so an analytics lead.
So an analytically that I see
is a person who's a translator
between what are the needs of
the business and what are the
analytic solutions that can
help to solve those needs.
So someone that understands
the analytics very well,
but also understands the
business problems and can do
that translation.
So I have analytics leads
for each of those areas,
and then data analysts
that report to them,
and this pool of data
scientists that work across all
of those verticals to serve the
needs across each of those areas.
So that's a little bit about
the org design and what we came
up with. And then it was
just going about hiring the team,
writing the job descriptions.
Just kind of a quick answer--
I see Catalina Moreno.
I'm going to call her out.
She is one of our top
and excellent senior data
scientist. So
kudos to Catalina.
What I'll talk about a little
bit later are some of the
really great work that she
has helped to build. So
we're really grateful
to have here.
If there's other Zoetis data
scientist on the call that I'm
missing as I'm scanning
through, I apologize for that.
So hiring the team was the next
thing and that took several
months to do that. And one
of the key factors for us was
being able to be flexible
in terms of location.
I don't know how many of
you are considered to be remote
employees, but I was hired
in during the pandemic.
And I was told, look,
you're in Indianapolis,
but we're a New Jersey
based headquarters,
we want you to be in New Jersey
if you want to, but you don't
have to. And so I said, well,
I think we're going to
stay here and they're like, OK,
great, so you're remote now. And
so when I hired the team,
it was always a remote
option if they wanted
to stay remote.
Some of them wanted to be able
to go into the office at times.
But that was really the key to
be able to recruit people from all over,
all over the globe actually.
So not just in the
US, but leave that
flexibility for remote work.
And so basically, all of
our meetings every day are virtual,
which there's
a lot of pros. There
are some cons to that,
a lot of flexibility.
I do miss that kind of
face to face interaction.
And just as a side note,
I was able to discover that
there are about 10 or so Zoetis
colleagues that live here
in the Indianapolis area,
and we get together
once a month for lunch.
And so that kind of gets
that face to face interaction we
take care of. So I recommend
that to anyone too.
If you're working remote and
there's colleagues that live in
your area, have a little chat
that you have, put that together,
and see if you can get together
on a periodic basis just to
interact and meet new people.
So that answers a little bit
of the question of the org design
and the build, and we
just slowly built it up,
just kind of rough sizing. We're
about 25. So not super huge,
but a very powerful and
mighty team. Very competent.
Kayleen and team here,
they bring in a lot of
experience from their previous
roles or education and are really
making a big splash in the company.
So one of the things that
I want to just talk through is
how we have helped to
promote data science in the company.
And so a lot of you are
probably leaders or you're
working in your companies,
trying to get momentum in terms
of making data science and
the power of data science
be more prominent in the company.
And so when I joined Zoetis,
it was pretty early on.
It was within the
first few months,
really noticing that there's
some data science groups that
exist, and we're bringing
in a data science team.
We don't want there to
be confusion around, OK,
why are there so many
teams, who's doing what.
We want to be more united,
be really a unified
one Zoetis team of data
scientists. So what we decided
to do was to create this
thing called the Zoetis data science forum
where we would meet
once a month and share
success stories with each
other, share use cases, share
code and best practices.
And so it started off with
roughly about 50 or so people
that would attend across all
of these different data science areas.
And we met for several months,
we'd be sharing things
and it was great.
And then the tenants started to
build up a little bit more and
more and then more and more
non data scientists started to come
in and want to be interested
in what was going on.
And so it was at that
point we realized, well, wait a minute,
why don't we open up this to be
much more accessible to anyone in the company,
not just have really kind
of technical kinds of topics,
but talk more about the
business value and what's the
business impact. And have the
data science in there as well,
but have it be in a
very easy to understand manner and then
have that be a way of
promoting what great data science work is
across the company. So
as we started to do that,
more and more people started
to comment and enjoy it.
And then
our CEO Kristin Peck got wind
of what we were doing and
wanted to come and join
one of the meetings.
And this was in September of
last year. So nearly a year
ago. And with her joining, the
meeting attendance bumped up by 50%.
And I'm going to show you
a chart in just a minute to
demonstrate that.
And afterwards, she was just so
thrilled with how the meeting went.
She learned so much and
wanted to continue to attend those
meetings as she told her
administrative assistant that,
I want you to put this
meeting on my calendar every single
month, and I will try to
come to as many as possible.
And I can tell you
that in the past
I think nine or so months,
she's been there about six
of the past nine times.
Our CEO personally attending
the Zoetis data science forum.
And she has become one
of our greatest proponents. In fact,
in our town hall just two weeks
ago, she talked about the--
actually, it was last week--
she talked about the Zoetis
data science forum in the
Global Town Hall and how
this is something that you should
all go to and participate in.
And by the way, over time,
we've built up now where
there's 300 participants and
she's like, all right,
JD's goal is to get 400,
so I want everyone to go to
the Zoetis data science forum and participate.
So that's been a tremendous
help to have such senior
leaders that are supportive
of these types of things.
And I go back to
building a data science team,
promoting the things we do,
and having the resources and
the advocacy that you really
need to accelerate as a data
science organization.
Having the CEO and your CIO,
all those senior leaders be
not just supportive but just be
strong advocates
for what you do--
there's really no
replacement to that. It's
incredible what you can do when you
have that kind of senior level support.
And we are so fortunate
to have that at Zoetis.
So let me pull this up.
One of our data scientists who's in
Ireland, Vincent Tennanty,
he normally joins this call.
I think he might be
on vacation today.
Let me see if I can
share my screen.
This is the app that he built.
- And JD, can I dig into what
you said a little
bit about the CEO?
So Zoetis is a big company,
not sort of like a five person
startup. So like--
- 13,000 employees
worldwide. That's right.
- Yeah, so getting the CEO
on board is no small feat.
What are some tips and
recommendations you can give to
people to form that
kind of relationship?
- I take no credit
whatsoever. It's completely her. Kristin
Peck is just an a-plus CEO.
You can see her on CNN,
anyway, see her
all over the news.
Honestly, so
one
of the things we have is
what's called digital fluency.
We were trying to
raise the digital
understanding, advocacy,
usage of digital technologies
in all its forms.
And so we have this initiative
called digital fluency.
And our CEO is taking that
completely serious to the fact where
she said, OK, I
want to learn how to
code an app, code an app.
And so our CEO, who's
as busy as she is,
got some of our leaders who are
coders and can help her to
mentor her how to code an app.
And she did it, she taught
her kids how to do it.
And
so she learned how
to code an app.
And then when it comes to
these data science topics,
she's personally told me that she
considers herself a student trying to learn.
And so I wish I had
some secret way of helping
you help your CEOs to be
more advocates of this.
But to be honest, it's just
Kristin Peck. It's all her. She's
a super supportive.
- There are a lot of
anonymous questions.
- Yeah, I'll pause
[INAUDIBLE]. Sure.
- Yeah,
let's see.
Can you share about some of
the key projects you and your team
are working on?
- Yes, yes. So
and to answer that,
let me just finish the story
on the data science firm real
quick going here and
let me share the screen,
and I'll get to that because we
use Posit it in a lot of ways.
So this is the
app now. Some of you use Zoom,
and we're using Zoom now.
I didn't realize this until just
a few months ago that you
can download the participant data
of all those that attended
your Zoom meetings.
And so we downloaded--
I think you can only
get a year's worth of history.
I wish I had known this at
the beginning. But anyway,
so we downloaded all this
data and Vincent, in his Whizbang
R coding skills
was able to really quickly
put this together and show what's
the meaning progress over the
past more than a year here.
You can see what
topic categories we've had.
VMRD stands for veterinary,
medicine, R&amp;D.
So we've had different
categories of topics,
we've had over 800 unique
attendees over the course of
these many months,
and you can see here,
in the past couple of
months, we've had over 300 attendees.
So there's 309 on
that one and then 331
the one in April.
And our CEO had attended
both of those as well.
So anyway, quick a
little visual. And then
I won't click on this
because it'll show actually employee
names in here. But it also
shows the attendees. So we can
track who has attended
the most meetings,
who has attended the most
number of minutes.
So you don't just log in
for one or two minutes,
but you stay for the
whole meeting, et cetera.
And so that's what
this shows are.
Now,
I will say that one of
our top three attenders is Catalina
Moreno who's on the call right
now. So kudos to Catalina.
She has attended every single
data science forum meeting
since the beginning. So
perfect attendance.
So now going back
to the question
of some of our major projects.
Still getting over COVID here.
I would say that
where we use Posit the most
is in the area of manufacturing.
So when it comes to how you
can make a real impact, whether it be
reducing waste, whether it be
finding defects, whether it be--
you're noticing trends in
the manufacturing process that over
time that are drifting in
the wrong way so you can make
corrective action.
All that requires
quick and easy visual access
to data as well as the smart
analytics to go on top of that
to help you get alerts and to
know when things are
going the wrong way.
And so one of the things that
Catalina and other really
brilliant data scientists on
the team have done is they've used
Posit as the base platform to build
a continuous
process verification tool.
And it actually has
multiple facets to it.
So there's different modules to
help you go through the entire
process of OK, I have all
this data that's been ingested, now
how do I set control limits
that make sense for this particular
control metric of this product.
So I'm measuring this,
whether it be percent
dissolution or some kind of
quality metric that happens at
the end of the manufacturing
process in that
product, in that site.
So for that particular
combination,
what's the historical data look
like and what are the control
limits that I want to set.
And there's all kinds of rules,
all the [INAUDIBLE] heart
control chart rules,
something bell, electric
bell-- what was it, Kelly?
I can't remember all the names of
the eight roles there you can select from.
And so there's a module
to then select the
control chart limits.
And that'll only
be given to a few--
the access will be given to
a few of our manufacturing colleagues.
So that's pretty powerful to be
able to set those control limits.
And then the more general
module will be to have that
continuous monitoring of those
and another module that allows
you to go in and actually
make annotations so you can type in,
OK, this particular data
point is out of spec,
here's the reason why.
And so that gets tracked.
Anyone can go back and see that
of why it went out of control
as well as things
like email alerting.
So
your process is drifting out
of control, it hit Control limit.
Now you get an email
alert right to your inbox.
And so then you can
quickly go and investigate.
So this is something
that hasn't been widely
utilized throughout
the company.
There's definitely control
starting in different sites,
but not a universal tool
that's been built to solve
this controlled charting
challenge across the board.
And that's one of the
benefits of the way that
Catalina and team have designed
the database and has to be scalable.
And so it's not just a bespoke
solution for just one of
our major sites or two.
But now the way the data comes
in and the way they formatted it,
we're able to take the
solution and basically say, if
your data
is being loaded into SAP and
so forth or into our electronic
batch record system,
then you have it be able to
be exposed to you, you can
create controlled
charts, et cetera.
So for a couple of dozen
of our sites or so,
we're able to do
this type of work.
We're in the process
now of validating it
and having some
alpha users use it.
So we haven't fully
deployed it yet.
And our goal is
to then have it be
GMP certified so that we
can make those types of GMP
decisions based on that.
But we've made quite a bit
of progress in that space of doing
a continuous process
verification.
So that's one.
And the next one--
I really should have Catalina
talk about it because she's the
main data scientist that's
been doing it. So Catalina,
I don't know if you want
to come off mute and--
or if you're going to talk
about the monoclonal antibody,
but just kind of high level.
I'll try to do it justice,
but--
So one of our major products
that we manufacture is a
monoclonal antibody.
And these are for different
products for dogs or cats.
One is Cytopoint which is
a product that is used for
basically itching,
dog's illness for
Librela and Solensia.
Those are for osteoarthritis
in dogs and cats.
And these are monoclonal
antibodies that need to be
manufactured as part of
those drug substances.
And those of you that are
involved in monoclonal antibody
manufacturing-- it's complex.
There's a lot of
variables, it's
a difficult thing to
really get your
handle on. And so
one of the things that Catalina
and team have done is they
have built a Posit app
that takes a lot of these
real time-- I'll
call it real time--
but very close to real time
process data from the
batches that are being
actually scaled up and grown
in our bioreactors
to be on our cloud platform
where things can get loaded and
deposit and then presented back to the
users as, I'll call it, near real time
visuals of what's going on with
the current batches as well as
some smart analytics.
So we have another data
scientist involved in this
that's from our team in Austria
who built some algorithms to help detect
when these very
complex multivariable
relationships show an out of control
signal and then send that signal to--
could be an email alert or just
signal it on the actual chart itself.
And this has been extremely
valuable. For one,
it's really hard
for these shop floor
engineers to be able to get access
to data because they might have to
log into SAP, download
a spreadsheet,
or they may have to log
in to their MES system,
download data to Excel, manually
manipulate it, which is
so cumbersome, whereas now,
we have it all flowing
automatically up into the cloud
platform which
then can be easily
and readily deployed through
tools like Posit to be able
to build these visuals and these
smart analytics on top of that
to be able to make better decisions.
So
in the area of manufacturing,
that's the area that
we've actually just scratched the
surface. So the
monoclonal antibody interaction process
has an upstream and a
downstream process. We've only just
tackle the upstream part of
one of those three products.
We want to do upstream
and downstream across all three
products and scale
across multiple sites.
So we've only done one site,
upstream only, and
of one product.
So you can see we have a
lot more we can scale and a lot
more opportunity to
increase the value of these
tools house and Posit across
our manufacturing network.
So that's a little bit more.
I can keep going. There's a
whole lot more things. But Robert,
is there any other questions I
should tackle or want me to
keep going on more use cases?
- Oh, there are a
lot of questions.
There is one that is
asked in the chat by
Ama. Sorry if I'm
mispronouncing your name.
I don't know if you
want to ask it live.
I'll give you a few seconds.
But if not, I can ask it.
I'll assume that
I'll ask it. Thanks for
sharing your experience--
MAN: Hello?
ROBERT BETHELL: Oh, come on in.
MAN: Yeah, thanks.
And thanks for having me.
I just want to go straight
to the [INAUDIBLE] time.
I know I'm based in
the UK in London and
I'm a student possibly working
on a startup with my co-founder.
And so was surprised about
that because it's a difficult startup.
And so I was asking
myself, we as students,
how you actually recommend
that's not, let me say,
a small practice-- like I
don't-- like I said, practice
[INAUDIBLE] getting the data
the data practice in-house with
a small team, just
basically three of us.
And so that's what it was
like coming from because you work
with big companies. So
it's like one [INAUDIBLE]
institution, how
do I go about that?
- Yep, got it. And
I can see that--
thank you for that question.
I can see your questions
here typed up in the chat.
I did have a little bit of
that experience when I did a kind of
startup business analytics
group earlier in my career at
Dow AgroSciences. Basically,
I came in and I was
given the headcount to hire three people.
So there were four of us.
So a small and mighty team,
really dedicated to help make
a difference using data and
analytics in our commercial space.
And I learned a lot
from that. I mean,
I learned a lot from mistakes
than actual successes.
So let me tell you
something of my mistakes
and then maybe that'll
help guide you.
And try to learn from those
mistakes as I've built this new
team here at Zoetis.
So
one of our first mistakes was to
try to tackle too many things at once.
And so part of it is, OK,
this is a really powerful
capability we want to make a
big difference, so let's try to
go as many places as we can.
Now there's some
value to trying to--
if you don't really
know where the value is,
you may kind of try to do
quick proof of concepts in many
places and whatever one is
successful, then you focus on that.
But I think we just spent too
much time trying to work on some
inherited projects that we got
instead of really trying to
focus on where is the
real biggest impact going to be.
It took us about two years
to get to the point where we're
like, OK, we found an area
that can really make a difference.
And then by the fourth year,
that's when things started
to really happen for us.
And that's when we narrowed
our focus and we honed in,
put all of our efforts on
just a couple of things.
Again, we're a small team,
we can only take on so much.
Just focus on one or two things
and just really do well at that.
And you heard this cliche
about quick wins. Well,
it's a real thing.
Showing some progress along
the way-- your senior leaders,
they want to know that they're
not just wasting their money by
bringing on an expensive data
science team that's going to
just go off and do
academic exercises,
but are going to actually
make a real difference.
Sorry, still getting over
the whole COVID here.
And so again, my
advice would be
narrow in, focus on
the highest value areas with
maybe two--
one kind of shorter term quick
win and one kind of longer term
according to the
company priorities.
Hope that helps. Next question?
- There is a
question from Sarang.
Sorry if I
mispronouncing your name.
Give you a second and ask
it live if you'd like.
SARANG: Sure.
Thanks for sharing
your experience.
It's been a really
good session.
My question was what approach
do you use to go from like
proof of concepts to
production ready apps,
especially from security data
governance and scaling perspective.
- Yeah.
Good, good. So we created
up front a six step process
where
we kind of went through each
as sort of stage gates to get
all the way to
long term value.
And the first step is
identification/prioritization.
So for our manufacturing
and supply chain leaders,
we had a small
steering committee of leaders and
analytics leaders that came
together and identified and
prioritize the highest
value use cases.
And that was the first step.
Once they identified those, then
we did the second step,
which is feasibility where we took
a little bit of time to
gather the data, to look at the
data available,
do we have enough data and
the right kind of data to do a
proof of concept.
And if so,
then we went to the next
stage which was a proof of concept.
And here's where
we would build--
we're talking the ideal would be
between two and four weeks, quick,
proof of concept,
using the data that we have
sort of in a sandbox or
offline, we're not building
production ready code,
we're not building
something that's ready
to go to the live.
We're just trying
to prove the value.
So that's really the idea of
a proof of concept. Two things--
can we do it and does
it have the value.
Those are the two questions
we're trying to answer with a
proof of concept.
And if the answer to
both of those is yes,
there's real business value and
we're successfully able to do it.
Then we go to the fourth
stage, which is the pilot.
And that's where we would
make it more production ready.
Here's where we were going to
partner with our
data engineering team to
take the analytic solution and
put it into production on a
small scale. And think of it as
maybe one manufacturing
site, one line
kind of thing where you're
not scaling it across
many different places,
but being more deliberate
in how you're doing it.
And this is kind of a risk
based approach
and we were given
permission to fail.
A lot of the proof of
concepts succeeded,
there were some that did not.
Or some succeeded, but maybe didn't
have as much value as we
anticipated. They were
good, but maybe not as high.
And so focusing on
those highest value
proof of concepts going on
to the next stage of piloting.
And then those pilots that
are successful, for example,
what I talked about the
monoclonal antibody is very
successful. We want to scale
that to other sites, other products,
other stages of the process
and
leverage what we learn there
and scale it across other areas.
And so that's that
scale up stage,
which would be after stage
five, the scale up after piloting.
Then the last stage is once
we scale that up, it's sustaining.
So how do we sustain
the value long term.
And so those six stages are
how we thought about it upfront.
And as a team, we
had the team size,
but also some
resources for partner support.
So we had also some consulting
support to help us scale faster.
And within the first year or so
of us getting started,
the total number of use cases in
our use case tracker was about 100
in various of those six stages.
Some were just ideas, some were being
prioritized somewhere
in the feasibility step,
some of the proof of
concept, et cetera.
But from there now,
we've taken the most high value
of those and we're actually
focusing more on those and how
we can highlight them and scale them.
Hope that answers
your question.
And in the regulated environment,
that was a part of it.
So
honestly, we're a little
less regulated than human health
here in animal health.
But we still have the
regulations in terms of clinical trials,
registrations,
we have to do
GMP,
all those kinds of things
on the manufacturing side as well.
SARANG: If I may
tack on to that question,
in terms of your stack,
do you only use R and Posit
or do you have any other
technologies that weave in to the
broader analytics platform that you have?
- Yeah. Yeah, so we
use we use a lot of
tools, I would say.
We're trying to consolidate
into one kind of workspace.
But we're not dictating to
every data scientist that you
have to use this tool or
have to use that language.
We've got Python programmers,
we've got R programmers that are
very strong in both of those.
Posit's nice because it allows you
to do either one of those.
We also use Databricks
as a way to use
Spark and Python code
or R code as well,
but mainly Python.
And a lot of the Azure tools
is what we use as well.
So we're in Azure shop.
SARANG: Thanks.
JD WILLIAMS: Yep.
- There's a question from
Bill. Bill, are you still here?
I suppose not.
Can you talk about your
relationship and work style and
challenges within IT and/or
regulatory department?
- Yes, so technically, we
were within our IT organization,
but we rebranded. So IT kind
of has this connotation of
network and laptops
and all that stuff.
So we're called Zoetis
Tech and Digital,
Technology and Digital.
And
because Wafaa came in and
restructured all that, it's been just
a very vastly different
culture and landscape than it was
prior to her coming on and
making those changes.
So the work style is
very collaborative and very
supportive in terms of our
analytics initiatives. We
have support across the board.
Everyone is aligned with
that strategic priority
of leading in digital
and data analytics,
empowering our business through
digital data analytic solutions.
And so
I would say that
it's been great.
Now one of the challenges is
sometimes-- so we have business
partners within IT or ZTD
tech and digital that are
pointed towards each of those areas.
Now they're responsible for all
of the technology and digital
needs. Say for
US commercial just to pick one,
now if we have
a data science use case
with US commercial,
we just need to make
sure that we're coordinating with those
business partners within ZTD
that are interfacing daily with
their US commercial colleagues
so that we're staying coordinated.
That's really one of the
challenges is not going off
kind of on our own but
really making sure that we're
involving the right people.
- So with all those various sources,
these standardized on certain data
formats like you say like
we'll accept CSV files,
JSON files, whatever.
- Yeah, so within
Azure is our data lake.
We've created data lake
within Azure. And honestly,
how the data
engineers ingest it--
I think it can come in
many different formats.
We land it into a raw
zone. Then from there,
it gets transformed,
put into parquet into
our governance zone.
And from there,
it can be consumed among
various downstream applications
and consumers and
data scientists, et cetera.
So yeah, a lot of different
ways. I think Javier has
hand up. Javier, do
want to ask a question?
JAIVER: Hey, JD.
Thanks. This has been really
interesting. I joined late. But
I'm at a
health care insurance provider
managed care business, and
there are several
teams already using
Azure
modules and apps and Power BI.
I'm more on the
data science side.
So I don't really touch
those tools too often.
So I'm a bit in the
dark in terms of their capabilities.
But one thing I do
want to research more--
it's the R integrations that
might make the Power BI
dashboards faster. This is
something, again, I
haven't researched at all.
But I didn't know if
you're using any kind of
R backend for
powering the
Power BI visuals.
- Yeah, great question.
Now I don't know of
any instances of that.
The backend
piece on the data for
our Power BI or from
basically Azure-- so
we use Data Factory or
SQL or something-- data
transformations, data storage,
and then the RBI dashboards
are just built on top of that.
And so we use R for-- the
way we think of it as--
so the whole process of data
is they're source systems,
then they get loaded into the
data lake in it's raw format,
it's transformed, then it's
governed, and it becomes
our data source.
And I think of everything
that we do in data science as
downstream of that curated
governed data. And so the apps
that we build using Posit
are downstream of that production data.
And
the Power BI dashboards
are also downstream of that
production data, but we don't
have Posit in the middle.
So we don't necessarily
use Posit it as a
data engineering platform to create
the data in its format.
I think, in general,
we would prefer to have
the data engineering
steps be done within
kind of Azure,
Data Factory,
all the SQL and all that
the massaging curating of the data
to happen there and have
the data ready for consumption
downstream of that
in general.
JAVIER: No, that makes
sense. Thank you.
-
The most upvoted question
on Slido is how do you
decide/design
requirements for DS, which
I'm assuming is data science,
versus DA, which I'm
assuming is data analysis,
other than their
academic background.
- Great question. So
we have created just last
year and launched what we
have is the career
framework, career progression framework.
And this came out
after I had designed the org.
So let me kind of give both
of those and how they come together.
So when I first
designed the org,
the idea was that we wanted
to hire people that can be really
good at manipulating data,
that can create visuals,
create dashboards, that can
communicate well with the business,
but don't necessarily have an
advanced degree in data science. So
analytics is a spectrum.
There's this whole
spectrum continuum
between someone who,
on one end, is
competent and familiar with
data analytics tools and capabilities
but not
necessarily you don't
have years of math
background and all the
math that's underneath it whereas
someone who has an advanced
degree in analytics and
multiple years of
grad school, has
all the mathematical
foundations behind and really
knows that very well, and
there's all the space in between.
And so we felt like there was
a lot of value in having both
ends of that spectrum.
And so
the design was to have
some data analysts
who have
bachelor's degrees.
And so the answer to the
question is probably the degree
being counted the most strong
indicator of what a data
analyst would be.
But basically,
these are people that don't
want to necessarily build models.
They're interested
in data engineering,
they're interested
in data visuals,
they're interested in solving those
problems kind of warm a
descriptive way and
aren't as interested in
machine learning or AI.
We have people
that are like that.
And those are our
key data analysts.
And they're a smaller group.
We have a much bigger
group of data scientists.
And data scientists are those
that have those advanced degrees
in
science, statistics, et cetera.
And then they really want
to focus on building the models
and refine those models, MLOps, all
those kinds of processes. And so
we have both those.
Now in late last year,
all of ZTD or Zoetis Tech
and Digital rolled out a career
progression framework
where we connected those
together. And so data analysts
that wanted to
progress to be a data
scientist would have that opportunity.
And it may mean that they
have many more years of experience
or may mean they get a master's
degree along the way. And
we're a company that
supports our team members in
furthering their education.
And so we would help them
along the way to get further education.
And so they would have an
opportunity then progress and
to go higher levels
in the company in terms of
being an individual contributor
within data science.
So I hope that
answered the question.
We both are highly
valued and needed,
used for different parts
of the whole puzzle.
ROBERT BETHELL: Yeah. Abdullah,
I see you have
your hand raised.
Maybe.
ABDULLAH: Hello?
JD WILLIAMS: Yeah, hi.
ABDULLAH: Yeah, thank you.
Thank you so much for
this interesting talk. So
I have some question
because just now, you are
talking about the background.
Actually, my background
in statistics-- recently, I finished
my PhD and applied on
the computations statistics.
So in my journey,
when I did my PhD,
I
took a lot of coding for the R,
especially for the coding.
So from that day, so I
am really interesting to just involve myself
in
the data science area. But
still,
I don't know the
way because, OK,
for me I have knowledge
for the statistics,
but I think the coding is not
much because it's just for
R, for me.
So what is your advice
for myself, OK?
- Yeah, yeah.
And the landscape has
drastically changed from when I
was a grad student
20 years ago.
So when I was a grad student,
I did most of my
dissertation research in Sas,
but I also use R.
So hopefully not offending
any of the R people here. But
yeah, so I did it in both.
And since then,
Python has become very
popular and more and more new
technologies keep
coming out. So
I don't know if I can fully
answer your question other than
say that getting
real job experience
and then learning new
skills along the way--
so job experience along
with constantly learning
is really the best way to
continue to advance yourself in your career.
The technology landscape
is constantly evolving,
there's new things
coming out all the time.
So trying to stay on top
of those and learn those new skills
as well as just getting
real world experience.
And being in grad school
is one thing.
Getting out and doing an
internship or getting a real
job where you're
solving real problems--
that's where the
rubber hits the road,
in my experience.
ABDULLAH: Thanks.
JD WILLIAMS: Yep.
So I see a couple of questions
in the chat here. So Oscar
says, from a
leadership perspective,
what strategy or sources do you
use to try to anticipate where
data science analytics
world will be going next
or do you follow more-- OK, yeah.
Oh, boy.
- You can almost cobble in
the next question about--
- Yeah, ChatGPT.
So yeah, ask ChatGPT
what's the next big thing.
So
I get I get a couple of daily
emails that come in from--
I think one is
CIO journal which has
some technology headlines.
So I try to keep up
with some of the technology trends in
companies, what they're doing.
So I'd say LinkedIn.
Just try to stay plugged in.
Whatever source you want,
stay plugged into
those kind of feeds.
It doesn't take long to
read some highlights and
the title of the article
or just brief summaries.
You can get through
those pretty quickly
according to your
interests. So I would say
there are some people that
are real forward thinkers.
I would also say that some
of the most forward thinkers
are really in the areas of
joint ventures
or startup areas.
These people that are
thinking about new business opportunities,
they're seeing trends and
they're putting lots and lots
of money to it.
Whenever you put your
money where your mouth is,
that to me says, OK,
there's something there that
we should pay attention to.
And so there's a few
kind of forward thinkers out
there that I've come across
that are in the kind of
early stage investing space,
a lot of them from California
that are thinking far ahead of
where a lot of us are in
terms of these technologies
and where they're going.
So some of these people saw
it coming well in advance.
They knew that this type
of tsunami would come,
and they're already starting to
create startups that would kind
of ride the wave
kind of early on.
So question-- you must have
been asked about how ChatGPT-- OK.
So yeah, the whole
generative AI
space has been an
absolute tsunami
of interest that has come
from Kristin Peck, from Wafaa,
all the senior leaders
to us as an analytics team
to try to tackle.
And we were able to onboard
some of the generative AI tools
using our Azure and
Microsoft partnership.
And we're starting
to test those out.
We're very early
stages in that.
I attended a call
last month with
probably 50 or so CIOs
from various companies, and
we're not too far behind.
There are some companies that are
farther ahead in their generative AI
use cases and so forth.
But what we're doing is we're
kicking the tires on the
tools, testing them out.
And we have a couple of
use case areas that we're going to
start to dive into here shortly
in terms of how these
generative AI tools can be used
within the Zoetis firewall.
That's one thing that's
really important.
The public version--
just word of caution
for all you out there--
never put company proprietary
information or customer
information into
the public ChatGPT.
We've already seen some
headlines of some bad actors
that have done that and
the consequences of that.
And so we've onboarded these
tools within our Zoetis
firewall so it's all
privatized and any
internal data that we use
days within the internal network.
And so that's the type of
experimentation and use cases,
proof of concept that we're
to tend to work on next year.
- Here's a really
fitting question that got
upvoted in Slido that I think
is a good one for the top
of the hour as we conclude.
And it's essentially,
if I can summarize,
Zoetis and you and your
team sound awesome, how
can they get hired.
- Oh, yeah, there you go.
Well, hey, I would say
that connect with me on LinkedIn.
I'd like to connect with
as many people as possible,
stay connected that way.
Constantly search the job board.
So we had this initial hiring
wave that happened when I joined
Catalina as one of those
hires. Thank you, Catalina,
for joining Zoetis.
She's a rock star.
And so we're always looking
for great talent out there.
And so I would just say,
let's stay connected.
You can find me on LinkedIn.
I'm happy to connect.
And
there's jobs that are posted. I
would say there are some jobs,
not necessarily my team,
but there are other data
science teams within Zoetis
that I know have been hiring.
So definitely check
the job listings within
careers.zoetis.com.
- Can I just poke it
that a little bit?
What are some soft skills or
sort of team skills that
you look at in candidates?
-
So I think of it in
terms of a couple of different dimensions.
One is the analytic
skills dimension and that's
table stakes. You have to
be able to talk the talk,
walk the walk, you have
to be able to code,
you have to be able
to do the stuff. And so
your technical expertise
is an absolute must have.
The next dimension I would say
is more interpersonal side. So
it's being able to communicate,
being able to understand
how to best communicate
with others,
how to work with others
that don't have a technical background.
And so there's a lot around
the communication dimension.
There's really a third
dimension in my mind,
which is more a business
understanding, business acumen.
Now I hire people.
I don't expect them to have
any animal health background.
I didn't have any animal
health background.
But we do anticipate that
people will take the time to
learn it and try to
expand what are the company
products, how do we make money,
for our customers,
what are their needs to
really understand the business side of
it because at the
end of the day,
that's what we're
here for is to help
our customers, help our
company be successful.
So three things-- analytics,
dimension, have to have
kind of baseline
level of competency, communication,
soft skills, being able
to understand and communicate
well, and then having the
business acumen to go with that.
- Awesome. And we're at
the top of the hour. So
we always ask how can people
get in contact with you.
I think you already
said LinkedIn.
But also any parting thoughts
or things you're super jazzed
about talking
about to round out?
- So my boss and I
got interviewed by
Forbes Magazine
just recently.
And so if you look on May 2nd,
you can see an article
there on Zoetis. So if
you just actually googled
my name JD Williams, Zoetis,
it will show up on one of
the things there. But it's on Forbes.
I encourage you to go and
read the article to talk about what
we're doing in terms of
analytics and data science within Zoetis.
So thank you, all.
Appreciate the opportunity.
Sorry I wasn't here about
a month ago. COVID's nasty,
don't recommend it for
anybody. Stay away from COVID.
- Awesome. Thank you, JD.
Thank you everyone who
joined and participated.
We'll be here next week,
same time, same place.
Have a great day, everyone.
- Thank you, all.